foreign
welcome back to another great episode of
careful voice today we have with us
Christian she's back oh hello Kristin's
back we also have Colleen over there
with Nick at the believe all women
sector
over here believe all men that's right
wait that's what the side is all right
this is the this is the this is the
menosphere that's the red pill boys
Redfield middle sphere no women red pill
boys I don't think men need any help two
cups of coffee please thank you
dude we haven't seen you in a little bit
we've been up to bangs uh just banging
just banging yeah yeah I like to cut I
need a I need a switch yeah it looks
good I like it thanks appreciate that I
almost have that same thing
I don't so let's move on you know what's
up about Banks I'm secure I don't have a
hair oh [__]
I think her hair looks great dude thank
you I think what you should do is join
the long hair team but then like shave
the front
like a Chinese warrior I wanted to get
the Kanan Lynch like the freaking hair
long on the sides
that's pretty classic yeah that's pretty
classic I think women would be terrified
of me they already are oh you think so
thank you I didn't think so do women not
like that look
you know do we like the look don't look
at each other just answer
I think if everybody had
already yeah yeah you look like a cool
bank robber yeah those guys steal cars
bro I think I would have to I would have
to take a duffel bag with me wherever I
get off of that
what you been up to Kristen no that's
literally nothing nothing okay you know
I go to I go to Mexico next week I
booked like a little teaching chart all
right but no my we've talked about my
dad do not go to Mexico yeah it's like
it's all red like bad stuff's going on I
heard it was prime time to go I'm gonna
but there's deals let's go let's go come
on this is the best time to go some
people say after natural disasters
terrorist attacks in like War it's the
best time to travel really yeah because
no one wants to go there yeah oh so yeah
New York like Mexico just get the people
kidnapped a couple of people you
remember that it just happened yeah yeah
and then so everyone's like oh I'm not
going there but it's like well that
didn't happen in Cancun now did it well
not a lot happens in Cancun exactly it's
pretty safe no Monterey I'm actually
doing a little tour out there so I'm
like oh no yeah I think it should be
good right what kind of tour are you
doing uh teaching judging it's like for
a competition out there oh I thought
you're going like on a tour like a tiki
tour or something
[Laughter]
I guess this happens in Hawaii or
something but they go to different tiki
bars oh there's one to another yeah it's
like a bar crawl yeah but like yeah and
then you get like off The Loop dude
you never had a life like that no no no
you don't have like a ticket to work no
not really bro I might drink with Steve
today let's go [__] because I'm feeling
crazy pour them up wow like half a shot
half a shot let me have let me get lunch
in my stomach but what part of you you
said you're going to Monterey Monterey
Chihuahua Guadalajara
so you're going through all those cities
yeah
and you're teaching them how to dance
yeah I do okay this is a question but do
I just speak in English or am I like
Cinco say siete I'll take this one
sound like a vacation
mom
do you have someone that's gonna be like
guiding I hope so I mean I hope so yeah
that'll be helpful it's like a legit
thing I I feel like they usually have
interpreters yeah yeah how good is your
Spanish
you feel pretty confident with yourself
answered in Spanish
that was pretty good no bien that'll
that'll get you like a good amount of
places I went to Guadalajara
you know I didn't know the ocean the
ocean all good restaurants I like the
ocean they're all cool phrases but
people were like trying to speak to me
in Spanish and like I would do a little
bit of that but it's really stressful
you get I thought you were uh a local
Chino no they knew I was no local show
oh then no they knew but like when I
would like answer them in Spanish like
yeah that's cool that's cool it's cool
Chinos
you didn't see a single one I brought
some chinos with me oh I brought some
Cheetos with me to Guadalajara and they
were all looking at me like we were at
this little uh food food Hall in the
middle of Mexico it was like it was like
next to this the first Catholic Church
out there or something it was old as
[__] right and then
um out of all the shops he chooses uh
Chinese food
was it good it was a Chinese dude in
there and I was like man Chinese people
go all over the world to open up a
Chinese restaurant yeah and then he got
like orange chicken and all this [__]
and I was laughing at him I was like I'm
gonna get authentic tacos right if I got
tacos and I'm sitting there and I'm like
this Taco's not that good dude
yeah he's idiots
oh this is so good you want an orange
chicken and I'm all like yeah so I ate
one
dude it's pretty it was good it was so
[__] good yeah why is it how come
like when you find obscure located like
Asian restaurants where they shouldn't
be they're really because they have to
work hard to [__] survive I guess
right it's not like here where they're
gonna open up anywhere and then people
still go I want orange chicken
you used to go to Mexico a lot I feel
like when you were running
uh have you guys seen the big ramp
slides that send you flying they're like
slipping fast yeah yeah I have gone
there like seven times there's one in
Tijuana and it's dangerous is the most
dangerous water park I've ever been to
in my entire themselves that yeah what'd
you say do they advertise that yeah no
fatality rate but you know how we have
rules like you can't run and stuff I had
the workers there were sending me down
the slide backwards some guy like gave
me a Cheeto before I went you can drink
beers down the slide that's what I love
about it because they have an ambulance
right next to the slipping
Mexican theme parks are like next level
we would we did zip lines where like the
zip line crashes you into what part of
Mexico
um
it was not Cancun but it was a theme
park next to it dude those are the those
are the dope ones like off like off the
side of the road it's like we went
through a zip line through fire there
was a ring of fire and [__] what the zip
line yeah and then how do you go through
if there's a line like yeah no no it's
around the whole thing around it it's a
big Ring of Fire like and then I was
like can I go on with Hannah and I was
like I don't know if there's a weight
limit or whatever right and then they're
like yeah if you want I don't think they
know either yeah they just hooked me and
Hannah on because and it went fast as
[__] dude because you know it goes by
weight
yeah yeah and there's ones where it like
crashes into rivers oh yeah you're not
even strapped on you're like in a
hammock it's like a hammock zipline and
it's just going down like this little
nut sack yeah yeah you're like on a
trapeze or something yeah like on a
circus no nothing holding you you just
like this and then you crash into water
chair there's just a little bit of water
good that's how uh in the Philippines
you there's like a you know when you go
to like Boracay or you go to like small
islands in the Philippines you have like
whole activity centers or just
everywhere with stuff like that and
they're dirt cheap they have this thing
called Zorb I don't know if you've ever
seen that where it's like a big it might
be called something different everywhere
but it's like a giant plastic sphere and
you're just in the middle of it and they
roll you down a mountain oh I've seen
that yeah yeah it's like but it's like a
big mountain yeah and then you just oh
but it's like inflatable so like uh
there's like a thick a thick area of
like it's like the Earth's mantle or
whatever and then you're in the core so
it's like a bunch of plastic
use those and they play soccer yeah
yeah you actually did that yeah yeah but
they feel like discombobulated
afterwards well yeah because you can't
you just can't tell where anything is
and they fill it with water partially so
that you can slide around and it's not
like scratching on your skin but then
like but then like the week after uh
like me and my friend did it we're like
that was so fun and then the week after
they had their first fatality oh my God
yeah the thing the thing went to the
side and it fell off the mountain like
we didn't think that could happen yeah
and a guy that died guard rails for what
dude actually but you know what's crazy
to think there's so much air in plastic
between your body and the ground so
you're good the dude died how did he die
like when you're going down a hole she
says a huge mountain yeah she kept
saying a giant amount this is a gigantic
[__] record-breaking mouth inflated
on the first right that's what either
why don't they do it on a hill either it
popped or it fell into the water I hit a
rock like one rock yeah the pointy ass
like knife rock yeah like the human egg
drop that you did in school where you
gotta like make a Contraption and drop
it that's a good game show
ing human version dude
growing up I watched Nickelodeon and I
realized how much my school district
sucked because everyone's doing cool
[__] like that and we didn't do any of
that stuff yeah no egg drop huh I should
drop soup
we didn't even get an egg to take care
of like it's a baby or nothing yeah yeah
I don't think that works who's to ever
do that thing where like you had a bag
of flour and you had to like take it
home as a baby that's really what you
had we had a fake baby no we had the you
either had to have the baby and take
care of it which like it could tell if
you fed or not or you had to wear the
bump at school for a couple days that's
big budget schools
we just had the baby that would like it
had no it had no legs when I think I
just had arms we just had actual
pregnant teens
a pregnant 14 year old yeah they were
just pregnant you just have to follow
her around to see what she goes through
you should ask her whatever well just
taking notes behind her
I'm just thinking of my own pregnant
friend
did you have to do that oh we got to do
that how did you do I think it was like
for two days it was like two days yeah
and we're like dude did you have a baby
bump huh do you have to wear a baby bump
no no my uh we had you scared a little
baby we had a little baby and then I
think it had like I said no legs which
was I thought it was weird I don't think
that's weird yeah you're right that's
not weird why would you say that dick
you're right so now people without legs
out there watching this and then they're
like oh great I'm weird to Nick I guess
you know I just mean if you're a
prosthetic baby you know I dug myself in
a hole Yeah but no it was just like
interesting it was notable that's why
the only reason why I brought it up yeah
and do they still have like
is that an ableist I don't know if it's
different it has to be different stuff
because the modern home of today or the
future would be way different than what
we had to worry about there's like how
do you microwave a TV dinner for
yourself I know like how to use an air
fryer or something oh yeah people still
don't know how to use that you know
what's funny like you know those things
like we were talking about how like some
schools would would make kids have these
experiences like give them a baby a bag
of fly or whatever we had one or we had
to uh to in order to feel what blind
people felt like they they made us all
go to El Dorado Park and we had to walk
the path like blindfolded no no but
everybody was messing around I don't buy
this [__] they were like this guy's
[__] around
no the school not you the your teacher
[__] around no but then like like
three of our classes had to do that but
like you you tell kids to do that
they're gonna [__] all we did was we
just go
the teacher's like yeah everyone was
cheating people were on a bender the
night before and he's like oh [__] I
don't want to teach anything put my
sunglasses on just [__] go out for
sure you guys had any teachers growing
up or you knew the night before they
were just partying hard now I know yeah
but I didn't know what the [__] was up
then they're just like oh I'm sick yeah
yeah yeah yeah I can't take a day off it
was your version
yeah yeah who is your teacher so we had
this we had this teacher uh it was in
sixth grade uh he was like a single guy
a little older we always wondered like
why I wasn't married all that stuff uh
we used to prank him all the time with
all this stupid stuff he was just one of
those teachers that would get mad and
when teachers get mad it's hilarious
because they're so serious and so we
would uh we would do all these like
things that we would we would like 30 of
us would spit on his car oh [__] holy
[__] we'd be like man it really it
started it started raining today did you
know that hey is this the same school we
went to no this is this is Bellflower
this is Bellflower where I went and then
um he would always be in a super bad
mood be like really
let's go
home
but why is he being so serious about it
yeah it's a gag so like so um
he would always like be in like these
different like like ups and downs like
some days he would be like overly happy
and sometimes he would just be like
super irritable and super mad and we
just thought it was so funny I also went
to the same forecast I also went to the
same church as him yeah he was uh I
think he was also a part-time organist
at the church I went to not a door super
dork and we told the church that he
diddled us and he got fired
he's just taking it and he's taking it
so seriously
he was so mad at us forever I guarantee
serious guys I guarantee you this story
is gonna end in a way that's worse than
any of you guys oh god dude here we go
the first video
classic Ryan Trouble boy super classic
so uh I I once I'm not in sixth grade
anymore I was in like eighth grade but I
still saw him every Saturday because of
uh Church Norwalk San Antonio and this
dude uh
he started just looking really like like
his he started looking really pale his
hair started getting really thin he
wasn't uh playing uh Oregon anymore I
and then I think he stopped teaching it
turns out this guy had AIDS and he died
of AIDS oh my God I was gonna guess he
got bit by a vampire
she was in a great mood sometimes he was
in a bad mood but we thought it was
hilarious because he was going through
medication and probably a hard time
you're spitting on his car that's
horrible
he's an AIDS victim like during the
height of age I know when AIDS was like
insane it was trending yes I'm a vampire
he's in this hardcore Christian like
group that he can't even be open and
getting real help I bet you your church
would have just been like damn that's
why that's why tragic bro you deserve it
you know no yeah it was really sad oh
yeah yeah he died died of AIDS yes oh
[__] I can make that joke because my
uncle died of it so okay my bad yeah
yeah but yeah it was like but like I was
like I think I was 13 when he passed but
then uh when I was in his class I was
11. and we were just a bunch of
Hellraisers and he hated us and then uh
yeah and then we we didn't know like
maybe he was like having symptoms this
whole time like we had no idea how did
you find out did they talk about it
after we talked about church like it's
just word around the church yeah yeah
they do know he died of AIDS like that
that's all the aunties
did you know Ryan
kind of yeah because he was he never
married like and he was like older like
I think he was like it is maybe 40s or
something he was a party boy so like
when in at least in our religion if
you're not if you're a single guy at
that age there's like questions already
yeah you know and um yeah you're not
getting married in your 20s yeah just
stay single forever right yeah he was
just kind of like a look at you
differently I think well my uncle used
to come all the time with his friend and
I just thought I was like oh my uncle my
hands are his friends
was it the same friend or was it a
different friend but he was like in the
relationship with this man but then like
my parents just didn't say like what's
up yeah I don't even know if they knew
if they're like hey like we 100 know
he's he's a gay guy or whatever I don't
I don't think any of us really knew
that's how it goes but then yeah and
then all of a sudden one day they're
like yeah Uncle Bob like he's so he's
very sick he has like AIDS I'm like how
the [__] did he get age
how old are you when they told you that
I was so this is like 90 95 I was like
10 years old like nine years old yeah
yeah and then I and then they're like oh
like uh you know it was one of those
dirty needles from the hospital oh oh
yeah they told us that in school all the
time yeah they always said that's how
you get it don't share drinks watch out
if a kid don't hug anybody yeah remember
that don't
play with him because they're like if
you sweat on him or some [__] yeah dude
the 90s was a crazy time for
misunderstanding Asians yeah I mean you
guys could have got AIDS from spitting
on his car apparently
we get it
yeah I forgot how much an Ultima can
transfer
yeah it was uh those are all dirt bags
dude did you feel great about yourselves
after I mean we felt bad about putting
him through so much [__] regardless we
just were like oh we're just idiots you
know but then um but the crazy thing is
getting your high boy [__] yeah and the
crazy thing is because of that religion
how strict it was you know like there's
so many uh people later on that I found
out were either like teachers of mine
that were either gay or yeah yeah or
they were or they became Trans in their
Elder years yeah all from your church or
from my church and school wow it's
almost like you were hanging out with a
lot of repressed people yeah it's I mean
the more hardcore the religion the more
repressed there are I mean there are
guys though that you clearly know
um and then like they come out and
you're like come on dude we all accepted
Ricky Martin I said that all a million
times about I mean not that like he fit
all the stereotypes with my eighth grade
teacher he was like I just remember him
getting mad at me because we he gave us
all styrofoam cups through this art
project and for some [__] reason I'm
just idiot I started cutting teeth on
the top so it looked spiky and he was
like
I didn't tell you to make spikes on the
cup and then I was like you gay and uh
like he and then he made he made my mom
come to school and like have a
conference like he's insulting me in
class and like made this whole thing I'm
like Mr Dave's gay definitely but this
guy was married he had kids and
everything super like uh high in the
church and everything oh you meant
literally yeah like a 1990s I I asked
him I asked if he was gay because he
came at me so like flamboyant about the
cup
and then um and then turned out later
yeah he was gay yeah he ended up uh he
ended up leaving his family yeah yeah
and I hit him up on Facebook I added him
like decades later and I was like did
you say I told you so
[Laughter]
that's the guy who called it
I was like I'm proud of you man I like I
was happy for him what do you say
because that's that's a hard thing to do
like I knew his kids and everything and
and he's like they're just on their own
now and he's hiking with his boyfriend
and I'm like let's let's go lucky he's
active that's good yeah yeah healthy guy
yeah as a personal trainer like he wrote
me back and he was like super excited
and happy and I was like he's like
you're finally 18.
got the son of a [__]
[Music]